في المقابل اعلنا كبير العسكريين الصينيين
رفض بيجين تصريحات وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
بشان الوضع في تايوان وقال الجنرال جينغ
ديانغ ان الصين تؤكد سيادتها التي لا يوجد
لها على جزر بحر جنوب الصين والمياه
المجاوره
يشعر الى انه وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
الذي سبق ان رفض عقد لقاء مع اوس وذلك في
خطوه لافته للانتباه شهدها منتدى شنغاريلا
للامن والدفاع الاسيوي في سنغافوره لكن
المتحدثه قال ان المصافحه جارت دون تبادل
اي حديث جوهري
الى انه وزير الدفاع الامريكي
الذي سبق ان رفض عقد لقاء مع اوس وذلك في
خطوه لافته للانتباه شهدها منتدى شانجريلا
للامن والدفاع الاسيوي في سنغافوره لكن
المتحدثه باسم البنتاجون قال ان المصافحه
جارت دون تبادل اي حديث جوهري
معنا من مقارنه عقادي مؤتمر حواري
شنغاريلا في سنغافوره مراسل الجزيره صهيب
جاسم صهيب اذا هذه المصافحه لم يبدو انها
اذبت ولو جزء من الجليد الان في العلاقات
بين واشنطن وبيجين كيف يخيم هذا التوتر
الان على اعمال هذا المؤتمر
فعلا موضوع التدافع الصيني الامريكي
والموضوع الاول في هذا المؤتمر مؤتمر حوار
شانجريلا او قمه الامن والدفاع الاولى في
اسيا في هذه القمه ربما في هذا العام
والعام الذي العام السابق ربما كان كان
الموضوع الاساسي وما زال موضوع الاساسي هو
موضوع تدافع الصيني الامريكي في المنطقه
حيث نرى ان هذا المؤتمر بانعقاده في
سنغافوره احد دول دول رابطه اسيان حيث تقع
بين المحيطين الهندي والهادئ هنا يتمركز
التدافع الصيني الهندي بشكل واضح المصافح
الذي وقعت الذي حدثت امس ربما كانت هي جزء
من محاولات هذا المؤتمر لاذابه الجليد بين
المشاركين باي شكل من الاشكال حيث ان هذا
ان هذا الملتقى لا يمثل اي تكتل او تجمع
معين بل هو مفتوح لكل وزراء الدفاع في
المنطقه وحتى من دول عربيه اوروبيه وغيرها
بالتالي المصافحه لن تنهي الخلاف ليس
الامر بهذه البساطه ولاحظنا ان وزير
الدفاع الامريكي هذا الصباح تحدث عن عدد
من الامور الاس في كلمته الافتتاحيه لهذا
اليوم تحدث عن تعزيز الحضور الامريكي في
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ من جانب ولكن
من جانب اخر اكد على ضروره ايجاد قنوات
تواصل مع الصين واكد على ضروره ان يكون
هناك قنوات تواصل بين المسؤولين الدفاعين
والعسكريين بدرجه الاولى حيث نرى ان
الولايات المتحده مهتم مهتمه بهذا بهذا
الجانب الى جانبي تقويه تحالفاته الثلاثيه
والرباعيه التي نشهد تزايدها في العامين
الاخيرين مع دول الاسيويه ودول في المحيط
الهادئ على الجانب الاخر يرى المؤتمر على
انه ايضا مجال لتعبير الصين عن وجهه نظرها
تحاول الصين كسب القلوب وايضا كسب
الحكومات وكسب مواقف الدول في دول الجنوب
شركه اسيا باستثماراتها الاقتصاديه
بنفوذها الاقتصادي المتوسع في هذه المنطقه
ولكن في نفس الوقت هي تواجه حساسيه حضورها
العسكري في بحر جنوب الصين حيث انها تزعج
بحضورها هذا دولا مثل الفلبين وفيتنام
واندونيسيا وغيرها بالتالي هي تقف موقفا
ربما مثيرا الجدل بين التوسع الاقتصادي
الذي يرضي كثيرا من رجال الاعمال وكثير من
اصحاب المصالح في جنوب شرق اسيا ولكنها
تزعج ايضا دول اخرى بتوسعها وبحضور سفنها
بشكل وباخر بازعاجها لهذه الدول في منطقه
جنوب شرق اسيا سنرى وزير الدفاع الصيني
لشانفو يتحدث عن موقف الصين وتصور الصين
لما يعرف بالمبادره الصينيه العالميه
مبادره الامن الصينيه العالميه ومغد
وبالتالي هذا المؤتمر هو محاوله لعرض
الافكار عرض الافكار الغربيه والاسيويه
الوسيطه بين الموقفين والصينيه من طرف اخر
دول اسيا الاخرى تحاول ان تقف موقفا
محايدا او تحاول ان توقف موقفا وسيطا بين
القوتين وهي تامل ان لا يتحول هذا التنافس
الى صراع او الى حرب بارده جديده شكرا لك
صهيب جاسم وراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من
سنغافوره